Speaker 1: We have an incredible bit of news.
The White House called a Trump rioter on January
6th.
Uh oh.
Why would that be the case?
Well, let's see if we can figure this out.
But this is blowing the lid off of yet another
part of the Trump riot investigation.
There's a CNN article that summarizes this
quite well.
Listen to this.
On January 6th at 4:34 p.m., a cell phone
registered to a Capitol riot, a rioter who
stormed the Capitol, got a phone call from
a White House landline.
CNN has obtained the records.
Other news outlets have looked at the records.
This happened.
White House calls.
Calls a Trump rioter on January six.
The call lasts 9 seconds.
Who placed the call from the White House?
Well, we don't know right now because the
White House has landlines and many people
work at the White House.
So we don't know.
Could have been anybody who works at the White
House.
Okay.
According to the records, the call came from
a two OTU number, which is the publicly available
number for the White House, doesn't show a
specific extension, so we don't know who's
whose phone it came from.
The call was placed in the late afternoon
right after Trump did the video message, saying
to the rioters, We love you but go home.
It's unclear.
CNN writes What, if any, connection exists
between the White House and the rioter, including
whether the call was made by mistake and whether
the call went to voicemail.
Mistake.
That'd be quite a coincidental wrong number.
Quite a coincidental wrong number.
What else do we know about it?
Well, we know who the call was made to.
The cell phone belonged to a 26 year old Trump
supporter from Brooklyn, New York, named Anton
Larnach, who traveled to D.C. the night before
with two friends, according to multiple sources
familiar with the investigation.
The three men attended the Stop the Steal
rally on the Ellipse, and then with hundreds
of others entered and illegally demonstrated
inside the Capitol.
They were charged.
They pleaded guilty in April, and they were
sentenced earlier this month.
All three declined to comment to CNN.
According to multiple sources, Lennox says
he doesn't remember getting that 9/2 call
from the White House and says he doesn't know
anyone who worked in the Trump White House.
The phone call wasn't mentioned in Lennox
sentencing or in any court documents.
And a spokesman for the U.S. attorney's office
in D.C. has declined to comment.
So what exactly does this mean?
And there are a number of questions here.
Number one, how do you not remember a phone
call from the White House that you didn't
get the call or you got it, but you don't
remember what was said or they left you a
voicemail or what?
You have no memory of it.
That's different than I never received such
a call.
I have no memory of it.
It's really weird.
It's obviously very difficult to believe that
it's a random coincidence there's a riot going
on.
Trump says to the rioters that he loves them,
but it's time to go home.
One of the rioters is at the Capitol.
And the White House.
It's like a dial.
Someone just happens to accidentally call
the phone of the writer.
Doesn't really make sense.
So it obviously leads to speculation.
Could it be?
Well, someone at the White House was in touch
with this writer, meant to call the writer
on their cell phone, but realized they were
using the White House line.
And so they quickly hung up.
Is that a possibility?
Again, we're left to speculate because the
official explanation so far don't make absolutely
any sense.
This particular writer, Linick, was seen in
the background of an individual named Baked
Alaska live stream from Jeff Merkley's office
on January six.
They'd broken into Jeff Merkley's office.
You can see in the background of a baked Alaska
live stream, is it possible someone at the
White House was watching the stream?
Saw Linick was like, Oh, that's the guy we've
been in touch with or I know that guy or something.
The other speculation is Linick agreed to
cooperate to some degree for a lighter sentence.
Is that related to why?
There seems to be no comment from anybody
and not much of a desire seemingly to get
to the bottom of who it is from the White
House that called linick.
Only questions right now, but the fact that
someone from the White House called this guy
on the day of the riots raises all new sets
of questions about the connections between
the Trump White House and the rioters.
Not generally, right?
Of course, you can say, well, generally they
were like, we'll make a speech and we'll say,
let's walk down to Pennsylvania that walk
down Pennsylvania Avenue and some of these
people are going to follow.
Okay, fine.
We knew that this is about the specific connection
between an individual at the White House and
this particular rioter on that exact day.
Will we ever know what happened?
I think we actually will.
I think it's likely that we will get to the
bottom of this.
Multiple news agencies working on it, but
it doesn't look good.
What do you believe is the explanation for
this phone call?
Let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show is, of course, an audience
supported program.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
It's called The Bonus Show.
We cover more stories.
I'm joined by producer Pat every single weekday.
And you can sign up easily for the member
show and the bonus show.
Both of them.
We do a member show as well, which is a commercial
free version of The Daily Show, available
hours earlier than we publicly release the
show, get all of it and more by signing up
at join Packman dot com.
I believe the normal membership prices are
very, very affordable.
However, we also offer a coupon codes.
No means testing.
Just if you want the discount, take the discount.
You can use the coupon code in date to get
yourself a tidy little discount at join Packman
dot com.